hey what's up i'm woman valderrama i'm
here with buzzfeed i'm going to take a
quiz to debunk
body myths
[Music]
is it illegal to cast a ballot before
election date starts
that is false many states offer early
voting
and absolutely ballots so i always like
to tell people that november 3rd is the
last day of voting
so you got until then to uh to send your
vote in
convicted felons are banned from voting
anywhere in the u.s
that is false it's a common
misconception that people with felon
convictions
are never allowed to vote again in
reality the loss
of this totally uh varied state state so
don't believe the hype absentee ballots
are only counted
if the election is closed that is false
absentee ballots count just as much as
ballots
submitted no matter how you get the vote
in they are always gonna count
college students are allowed to vote in
the state
where they go to school i think that's
false
oh i got that wrong damn it college
students can vote
where uh they go to school some states
have made it illegal to take a selfie
in a voting booth i'm gonna say true yep
got that right so stepping a photo in
the voting booth uh in your polling
place or
of your ballot may indeed be illegal in
your state
you can avoid jury duty by not
registering to vote
i can tell you that that is false all
right because there's no way
they're not gonna they're gonna get you
off the hook on that you can vote
online or via tax in every state
i'm gonna say true ah that's wrong damn
man you should you should be able to you
can't text your vote anywhere
some stays will allow citizens uh to
email their ballots
if they need certain qualifications the
outcome of the 2016 presidential
election came down to a group of voters
so small they could fit inside a
football stadium
true that is absolutely true and i got
it right despite losing the popular vote
donald trump was able to win
the electoral college vote by fewer than
80
000 votes identification is required to
vote in every single state
true oh no it's not well get that wrong
too
man i'm really messing up right now guys
id is required in many states but not
all
if you don't bring id to the polls and
your state requires it
you will be turned away i'm gonna say
that's true oh my god i got it wrong too
damn it oh god you can still fill out
a professional ballot a provisional
ballots are counted
so if you forgot your id the poll
workers cannot find your name in the
system so be sure to request a
provisional ballot
there's no way to vote in 2020 without
risking covet that is
false i can tell you that i got that
right you can still vote safely even
in this pandemic pandemic mail-in ballot
aka absentee ballot
to vote from the safety of your home
many states uh also allow you to vote
early in person
you got 7 out of 11 right man you know
i'm really grateful for the ones that i
got wrong
because that turns into wisdom sometimes
making mistakes just makes you a wiser
man
do your part show up and uh show up
because it works
you